oh
hello party people and welcome to honest
trailer commentaries for you guessed it
avatar the last airbender oh man what a
good one
uh what a good show that is but if you
watch this video
you'll hear our behind the scenes
thought process go into some more detail
on the trailer
we're gonna watch it together we're
gonna talk about some deleted scenes
because we cut a bunch of stuff from
this one including a surprise from
prince zuko himself
uh and we'll respond to questions uh and
complaints from viewers like
you so uh joining me today is lon harris
daniel radford
and joe starr who i i must mention is
doing the fandom five trivia on avatar
the last airbender
next friday not this friday but next
friday
this friday no sorry this friday it's my
fault this friday yeah it's this friday
and yes the blood contract you have
signed requires that
you know that at the top of the show
yes so sign up for that and win uh 650
dollars
man that's good that's that's a lot of
money for answering
questions about avatar the last
airbender airbender
he'll sell you air like in spaceballs
having written all of these questions
some of the answers will almost
certainly be discussed on this show so
if you're watching right now
yeah it's like prep this is your study
guide
on the last airbender is after uh aang
privatizes the post office and like
takes off
uh perry air selling chinese food and
blade runner he's the last air vendor
wait you mean fifth element the guy on
the guy
right he's in like a flying boat he's on
the ground in blade runner my mistake
just talking about the important stuff
uh because the last thing we want to
talk about is avatar the last airbender
because it's really good what else is
there to say
what do you guys think yeah uh this show
is great i love
uh this show a whole lot and
um to the point where uh i think you
were getting frustrated that early
drafts of mine for this
just had no jokes or bad things to say
in them and they were yeah joe's first
draft on this was a real
um just a real dick
there you go i didn't want to get
demonetized you're responsible for it
uh yeah a real air job of them
and that's fine because it's great um
and i don't think that we were
unfair or cruel uh at any point but yeah
but correct me from wrong
but that's the challenge is like what's
what's funny and what's different about
this to me
again very difficult this is such a good
show i never actually sat down and
watched it all the way through
but man it gets it tucks into you and
like it's very bingeable
um i was not expecting that uh it has a
beautiful
uh rhythm and cadence to it where it
keeps pushing along this overarching
story forward
but every week it's like oh where they
go where are they gonna discover this
time what new power what new town
um so just just fantastic all around i i
got nothing bad to say about it
yeah it's also it's very creative like
even once it's sort of
you know once you get the whole premise
and the kind of casey comes there
they're endlessly inventive in terms of
how bending works and how different
people can use it and how it sort of
weaves its way into every aspect of the
society i think a lot of shows
they kind of have that mythology and
then once you get it it's like
relatively unchanged it's like well
they're just gonna keep
pigmented powers but avatar every
episode every season like really kind of
reinvents the wheel in terms of
you know everything the whole premise
from the ground up and so yeah it's only
three seasons and it keep it remains
really involving the way through
yeah uh danielle any uh what are your
avatar thoughts
i i get it it's really it's just a
really good
show and i know that obviously we make
the joke and we'll talk about it in
there
um about how it's four eight-year-olds
but it is one of those shows where
um like truly all ages because i think a
lot of shows call themselves all ages
it's like no
you're for kids and you're you're saying
you're all this is really
an all ages show um it is really uh
it because it does appeal to obviously
like it can appeal to a younger audience
but there is stuff in there that is
definitely uh for us for the adults
um and a lot of the themes it does that
thing that uh
kid shows kids shows got really good at
which
is finding a way to tackle really heavy
subjects
in a way um without being super preachy
uh but that is translatable for kids for
the children yeah
it's great and um something we'd kind of
neglect to mention
uh at any point is like it's beautiful
like it's
it looks great um they did not skimp on
the action scenes and they were like
fairly consistent throughout uh like it
wasn't like they
like dbz where they there was like 12
episodes of filler and then you had
something cool that they spent money on
i actually wonder how they were able to
pull that off because it even stands out
among animation of its time like yeah
even kids action shows
any show that immediately brings to mind
miyazaki like it's obvious that this was
inspired by miyazaki and like they're
bringing that
if any tv show can pull that off it's
like very impressive because those are
the most beautiful highly detailed
animated movies ever made really
and there's very often a drop-off in
animation quality too once it gets to a
point where it's kind of hooked you
they can be like well we can pump these
out faster and we've already got you
with how pretty the first you know
couple of seasons are so
a lot of times the animation quality
will go down and it was really nice and
it does also help that it's only three
seasons um that it stayed
so consistently detailed and gorgeous
and fluid throughout
yeah it got it got better actually i
think looking back at book one or season
one it it it's a little
more um flat and and uh less dynamic
than it was by the
by the finale i mean my god yeah um and
you never have
i think really is where you start to
notice like oh it's like huge
and everything is really detailed and
colorful
and yeah yeah you never had that awkward
fourth season or whatever like
x-men the animated series got where they
changed studios and like
you can make it but on half the money
good luck and it really is
i think it's interesting that you said
how bingable it is because it really
does feel like it's almost designed
to be streamed and binged because they
pack so much
into a 22-minute episode um that it
feels like you've got like an hour's
worth of episode in most of them
uh even some of the goobery the more
goobery like standalone apps like they
pack a ton
in but it's only 22 minutes so yeah it
really is designed to just
get cranked through and binged baby yeah
this is the kind of show that like this
animation makes me feel
old because this looks so much better to
me like as good as you can make like a
clone wars
type show i don't mean to gang up on
clone wars i like that one too but
i like no matter how good you make that
tv cgi
animation it just never looks as good to
me as this so i don't know if that's me
just like well this is what i'm used to
or like cell animation just legitimately
being
being better i get that because um
uh we just finished uh dragon prince
over here and that's more sort of like
cell cg
and it gets better after the first
season
uh and it ends up looking
really good but uh i i i would prefer
hand drawn
too it's just a personal preference
android i mean obviously it's computer
aided
everything is days they're not like
taking photographs of of pieces of leaf
paper but
it's just always going to be more
expressive or
not always but it is for now more
expressive to draw by hand because you
can do all those
cartoonist tricks that have been
developed over the last 50 years like
when ang's face completely contorts or
like blows up and gets red or
whatever like you don't quite do that
with with cg or like if you don't like
dreamworks face
love a good dream just better at it
god i actually do that and there are
photographs of me doing stand-up
almost all of them i'm doing dreamworks
not on purpose
that's when i shrek impression i do an
ace track impression
yuck uh all right let's watch the honest
trailer for avatar last airbender we'll
have a lot more to say
as it goes
first they brought you slime then they
grossed you out
now nickelodeon brings you their
crowning achievement
the best appropriation of asian culture
since ghost dog way of the samurai
now pause everyone should watch ghost
dog way of the samurai so good
yeah i i think that was a a less popular
reference than i think originally we had
wu-tang clan or orange chicken or
something like that they originally had
wood tickling and then i was like maybe
wu-tang clan and orange chicken
but that clip that ghost dog clip i mean
just so good perfect just gotta do a
little uh
roof martial arts before yeah this one
was one for us
yeah it was if we can introduce the
fandom of avatar to the phantom to the
small but mighty fandom of ghost dog way
of the samurai there
yeah there were two fans out there in
our there was already someone in the
comments
who was like i had to google ghost dog
and realize
that they made a movie about how i act
when i sit at home alone and watch anime
and so
it's already i feel good yes
it's for sword guys everywhere yeah it
is yeah i can totally imagine
jim jerusha like uh like he like does a
snap kick
like his underwear into his hand and
he's like i have an idea for a movie
i could be a samurai uh and so could he
he's gonna do like one
indie film for every subculture it's
like dudes who are really into vampires
get one
dudes who are really samurai swords get
one like she's gonna work his way
through the whole all the subculture i'm
looking forward to his snake guy
yeah it's coming it's coming let's
let's keep going
avatar the last airbender
experience the show that everyone loves
and since it's been on netflix
no one will shut up about
full of bright colors silly jokes and
simple life lessons that will delight
your inner eight-year-old
because this show was made for actual
eight-year-olds
but who cares i'd give my first point if
it meant we'd get a season four
why didn't they make a season four
anyway shyamalan
and rewards so i was shocked that that
the movie
had that effect on this i i saw i i
forgot to
mark it down but somebody disagreed with
this in the comments but this is the
article i came across
um was the creators talking about how
they were pulled off
the show or they pulled themselves off
the show to work on this movie which is
shocking that they were involved in it
at all
um yeah yeah i don't think that the
movie is a
i don't think the show is missing a
fourth season um
it didn't really like it would have been
more of an epilogue i think i was
reading that like it would gone
more into azula's like redemption like
her and zuko would have had an arc but
it seemed like they had tied everything
up pretty well yeah they did um they did
comics to
bridge afterwards and i haven't read
them they might be great
uh i don't know but i sort of looked at
the
synopsis for them and i was kind of like
i don't need any of that
yeah i mean it ends in a really like it
feels like a natural
conclusion to the story they've been
telling which is like
development into the avatar and like
learning what he needs to in order to
protect the world like
that story sort of wraps itself up so i
feel like it ends in a pretty good place
it's like the buffy comic books uh buffy
season eight where all of a sudden buffy
like might be gay i don't i i mean you
know i i'm all for buffy making out with
girls or forever i
or whatever i i don't not necessary yeah
right
yeah like i don't need to see zuko find
his mom like
i love that the show ends on that very
painful like cliffhanger for him like
that's interesting
yeah um it's also like it's weird that
the guys who made the show worked on the
shyamalan movie at all because it's such
a like a weird wrong-headed take on how
to adapt it in the first place
like like they're trying to pack so much
of the show into this first
one movie when you like watching the
series you totally get what the first
chapter in this story would be i mean it
had to feel like being handled right
where shyamalan's like i
absolutely want your input i love and
respect yeah so much and then anytime
they'd give notes he'd kind of he was
probably like that's a great note but
also
i make moves right also here's what i'm
gonna do had to feel so frustrating
i get i guess that must be the story
because it doesn't feel like
when you watch the movie it doesn't feel
like the hands of the original creators
are there
at all yeah it's literally in the dark
you can't see
they couldn't see what was happening
each with its own stereotype i mean
personality type
i mean element solid earth flighty air
soothing water and fiery fire
where warriors known as vendors can
fling stuff around by doing karate next
to it
masters of martial arts can turn their
bodies into living weapons
and every animal had sex with every
other animal
komodo chicken it's a wolf bat giant eel
badger balls baby saber tooth moose lion
cub
love is love is love is best not to
think too hard about it
everything uh yeah all those animals
at some point in their lives port all
port
and i had a note on that because i'm
very confused how are the wolf in the
back
look listen we're we're taking a pretty
big leap here it could be like they
mutated this could be like a
post-apocalyptic
radioactive but they also have and they
even like put a
hang a lantern on it of like the
existence of just single
the bears right yeah there's just a bear
that's just a bear yeah and they're all
perplexed that's such a good bit
oh that bear is not going to bang a
caterpillar that's yeah when
i saw that episode and i was taking
notes on it i was like oh this is
genius this is going to be that it
didn't make it
saying that i mean in the words of dumb
and dumber it must have been some kind
of lube
yeah um and then just anything on uh on
bending in general i thought
you know bending's cool there sometimes
the people who work in the cities like
bending they reminded me of the
dinosaurs and the flintstones
who would turn to the camera and say
it's a living it's like you just have to
like raise and lower the elevator or
make the carts go all day
my favorite bending moments and there
aren't actually as many like in my brain
after watching the show i thought there
was a lot more of this than there
actually is when i had to like notate it
but it's when people don't need to bend
they just
gesture with bending i love that like
sometimes where you just get frustrated
you're like damn it but it's like with
fire
you're like and then like a rock gets
thrown into the atmosphere like
that would be so cool in your day-to-day
life good way to punctuate
like fire some water out of your hands
because you were upset
my issue with fire great tic tocs my
issue with fire bending
um and granted as you said it's a show
for children
where's like the like flesh melting off
somebody's bones you know where's the
horrifying
uh uh you know complete like screaming
in agony as they burn
i feel like fire usually just like
pushes somebody back
they just go ah i got hit with fire oh
that's
that's annoying i think it's the the
eight-year-old thing i think yeah i
think
yeah i think i think you hit the nail on
that although a hard r
anime adaptation of their best could be
awesome oh god no don't get me yes
don't make it grim they like put snyder
power rangers short films yes it was
just a complete
psycho in this one just like belting
people
uh although i will say one of the
interesting things about
um uh the eight-year-old of it all for
fire where oh it pushes people back or
it knocks people down or whatever is
that the moments where
it does actually burn someone to make a
point in the storytelling or something
like are actually really impactful
yes yes but it's always story based
burning no one ever just like
dory bass burst yeah i want like a
starship troopers like the arm
like turns to molten and then like
sloughs off it definitely has that like
atm i know that arm
stopped the guys have guns but they
shoot like the boxes above you
to fall on you rather than like pumping
you full of lead yeah it's a little bit
of that yeah they they they wrote
themselves in a corner with fire because
like there's a
hardcore like japanese spider-man yeah
everything changed when the fire nation
attacked 100 years ago
and then nothing changed for like 95
years
because neither side is making progress
now
only the avatar can end this fire fest
once and for all
a an elongated baby with a down vote on
his head
he's a kid struggling with air tension
deficit disorder
don't start without me boy remember the
reason we're here
all right time to practice water bending
who screws around all year
then freaks out the week before finals
the invasion's in four days
rounding out the abateans is guitar a
moon-powered reiki enthusiast
i can feel a lot of energy twisted up
around there tough
a barefoot blind badass straight out of
a tarantino movie
sorry shoes
it sucks i think it was too it was too
niche
uh uh hopefully to do the uh the i think
his name's
dan schneider is that his name the the
producer
the nickelodeon producer who puts this
in everything
he's the guy from head of the class yeah
and icarly yeah
uh uh who's like quentin tantru for kids
which makes it so much more wrong
and disturbing um ew i didn't know about
this oh yeah
well that's why that's why we didn't
write it in because uh the
the less you know the better on this one
and like tarantino is like on the
foot creepy foot guy spectrum
tarantino's on like the safer side
at least they're all adults oh it seems
like they're all
who knew what they were getting into
when they took off their shoes as far as
i know but
yeah but he is he did work at
nickelodeon which made me think like
he's like i have one note on the
character should we see your feet
a wikipedia
a men's rights activist guys are better
at hunting and fighting and stuff like
that
it's just the natural order of things
who over the course of the series has
the misogyny literally beaten out of him
in a performance so nice he's doing it
twice
something so strangely familiar
boomerang no shade here get that soccer
money bro
and oppa
uh the next series specific character
show up
like three times today hunting the
heroes is a family of villains who map
perfectly onto the targaryens
and the lannisters leading the charge of
these twisted fire starters
is zuko an outcast prince made of fire
and angst it keeps exploding in my face
like everything always does whose one
purpose in life
is to count i need to capture the avatar
finding the avatar
is far more important this coward's
hundred years in hiding are over i want
the avatar
i'm chasing the avatar where's the
avatar what a stunning view
the only view i'm interested in seeing
is the avatar in chains
oh we get it already i didn't capture
the avatar
who cares by his side is the big
lebowski of the fight
something we didn't touch on that uh
lana i think he brought up and i think
is a
good point but it's tough to phrase is
that like this is a universe
where teenagers do all the good and cool
and important stuff
not even like these three teenagers are
like the only ones who haven't figured
out it's funny because it's a show for
teens and that like that makes inherent
sense like
teenagers do feel like they're the only
ones everybody else is an idiot
and like if we were in charge we would
have figured out these problems a long
time ago
and like i think this show really speaks
to that world view because they
they they travel everywhere everywhere
they go like yeah
this village has been under water for a
hundred years that we don't know what to
do about it and then aang's like why
don't we just do this
and then it's fixed yeah and there i
will say teenagers and eccentric old
old people eccentric elderly people
those are the only two types of people
who matter in the avatar universe adult
regular adults useless
absolutely screw you 30 something
definitely the best example of kid power
since pete and pete took on the
international adult conspiracy
yeah exactly
it's like you know like in the grand
tradition of like e.t where all the
adults are like
i don't know just turn them over to the
government you know and like we're evil
and the kids are like nah we can figure
this out we're plucky yeah
we're plucky we're [ __ ] what we're
the monster squad
come on all right keep going
general iro a magical uncle on the hunt
for some tna sharing tea with a
fascinating stranger
is one of life's true delights
your beauty is intoxicating
more tea please in case someone brings
home a lady friend
this is the best tea in the city the
secret ingredient
is love i didn't see you get it with the
tongue
these two will carry the emotional and
thematic weight of the series with
satisfying character arcs that will
bring tears of joy and sadness to your
eyes
and then there's the other two they're
just mean
do you like overarching stories or are
you more of an episodic plot person
to that avatar answers yes as the show
balances serving the main quest
with a weekly dose of villages that need
help villages that get burned down
because they helped
soccer complaining stupid swamp dumb
ugly vines
guitars so you you said
joe that that the swamp episode was what
stopped you from
getting into the show cause i love the
swamp episode no i it's um i had never
seen avatar before
and any time i was channel surfing
because i am of an age where that's
something that you would do
um uh that was always the episode of
airbender that i would catch
it would be like at some point in the
swamp episode
this show takes place in a swamp
pieces of the swamp episode like four or
five times before i was finally like
okay
let's uh let's let's let's do this thing
it's honestly hard for me to imagine
like i didn't get into the show until
way later when people were like it's
great you should watch it and i
like binge the whole thing straight
through that's like the only way the
show makes sense to be like i can't even
imagine jumping around and just being
like
watching a book three episode out of
context like that seems like yeah
definitely not the ideal way to do this
i don't know and that one
my experience was just catching it on tv
and be like oh this show's really cool
and
like uh what's happening yeah it's still
cool
but that but it yeah i think literally a
dvd
was like my first time through we
finally jumped in about like while
book two was like halfway in progress so
i i remember like comic-con dropping the
seas
the book three trailer and getting to
freak out a little bit so it was kind of
like
i don't know it was like starting harry
potter like somewhere around order
and then like having the last couple of
you know those
last couple of midnight releases come
out we were like okay i'm a late bloomer
but i still get to
but i did just really like i would have
been hooked immediately because i really
like the uh
we'll call them floridians those guys
are like
they're like fan boats or whatever
they're doing i absolutely love this
gator
episode yeah yeah hugh swamp swamp
benders
he was at you
good stuff that was one of my favorite
like random different that's what i mean
if they don't just stop with like well
here's what waterbenders are like
and here's what earth vendors are like
like within those categories they still
put a lot of thought into like
well the waterbenders who come from this
environment would be like this and the
sand vendors that come from the desert
would be
like this and it's like the the fact
that they managed to keep so
endlessly kind of inventive about it
right through the end is really
impressive
and also you know keeping up with that
weird uh
anime tradition of having some very
southern
characters just randomly appear in your
tokyo set series
yes it's like from the greats it's an
all asian world but then like there's a
florida right in the middle
yeah yeah okay keep going
i'm dumb ugly vines guitar getting
preachy
it's not like i'm a preachy crybaby you
can't resist
giving over emotional speeches about
hope all the time i know
sometimes it hurts more to hope and it
hurts more to care
but you have to promise me that you
won't stop caring and aang searching for
a teacher to help him master the
elements
even though what he really needs is a
master to help with his blood sugar
issues
i'm sorry we got your back thanks
oh somebody catch him he's gonna hang
don't forget to eat your breakfast
before you fight the fire lord
so celebrate the show that challenged
kids with difficult themes
selfless duty calls you to sacrifice
your own spiritual needs
in between all the goofy sound effects
that's probably the closest thing we
have to a successor to star wars
in that the original is beloved but
nitpicked and the sequel pissed a bunch
of people off
uh i've not seen any legend of korra
uh um how does this panel feel about it
i have
i haven't finished quora i saw the um
the first season and uh
i got to go back and get all my facts
straight but uh
they a different animation house did the
first season and it just so it doesn't
look as good
and because i think there was a lot of
shenanigans for the release of court
because at first it was supposed to be
like
three specials or i think they they
hobbited
the last second it got yes it grew in
the telling yeah
yeah it kept growing in the telling uh
and so i think
nickelodeon then realized if it was
gonna grow in the telling they couldn't
half-ass it with like uh
a different animation house and so
eventually i think it gets better but um
like animation-wise and stuff like that
but so yeah i haven't finished the show
yet
yeah i mean i i like it i don't think
it's i don't think it's as
polished and as sort of tight as avatar
and i was going to also echo what joe
said like
it's not quite as sort of painterly and
like fluid
it doesn't look quite as good as the
original show i still like it though i
think it gets unduly
criticized like i think it's a it's a
cool interesting way to follow up
and i like that it's like they totally
once again like they totally reinvented
the world it's like way later
and it's like now it's a technological
world with cities and
it's not just like let's redo the same
show but for the next generation
oh well no wonder people don't like it
because they didn't just exactly
they didn't they could have really
easily just been like well here's the
next avatar and here's our journey
um but they didn't they totally
rethought the premise from the ground up
which
they ryan johnson airbender
well we'll find out danielle i know you
you said you love it and
but let's pretend we didn't hear that
because you and eric are going to review
the legend of korra this friday correct
yeah yeah
we're going to do a little review i
believe
that's going to happen right before
joe's trivia
all right um yes that'll be really fun
sick yeah
the trivia will be live the review won't
be
we're gonna take the review ahead of
time yeah all right
uh do it live we'll do it live
keep watching this fun trailer off
oh well at least no one will ever try to
make a live-action adaptation ever again
why must we fly so close to the sun
story
look i know that they're doing it this
time but i just
i don't there's just some stuff that
just looks good
as a drawing honestly i think vending is
one of those things
i don't really agree i think you could
make like a cool filmmaker who knew what
they were doing and was thoughtful about
the action could i think bending itself
could look cool in a movie
i just think it's the the nature of the
storytelling that makes it so difficult
because we were talking about how it's
like this perf it's perfect for tv
it's like a perfect blend of like
monster of the week village of the week
adventure of the week and here's the big
season long arc like i don't it's better
for tv
that kind of story than a movie but i
think like just the idea of like
somebody picking up a rock from the
ground and like chucking it at you could
be cool in a movie
nah call up justin chatwin and emmy
rossum get him on the phone
i want to see that rock chucking show
check rocks just the vendee when the
action scenes are on i get why
anybody would watch this and be like oh
this would be cool in a movie like two
guys having like a fire duel like sure
it's just like how do you take this
massive story in this whole world and
like
knock it down into like a two-hour story
it's the
thing of it is it's a retelling of
the appatines that we know and love or
is it a new things
no it's a retail yeah i mean i feel like
they're gonna at least try to do the hit
the beats of the story
okay all right
this trailer fun
starring the nature boy whoa
this is katara she's got my back okay
boomerang
before pyro red
spill the tea yoshi warriors
come out and play cat boss
swiper no swiping stop trying to make
fetch happen tyler
i'd like to take his face off female
cosplayers at comic-con
chan and ron john no joke here just a
big fan
netflix synergy there's no floor it's
just a river of lava
hey
your final test is endurance to the
death
and let this be the end of this rivalry
would have to
do his old father i'll be outside if
you're man
enough to fight me stand and fight
avatar oh
were we fighting do you really want to
fight me
i really do you two must duel each other
i order you to fight an agni kai
but spooky spirit stuff
hey come back
spirit magic doesn't work that way saka
it's more like
first base what if we kissed us
kissing i don't hate you i don't hate
you too
so he uh paused
joe you had a good point in our uh in
our other video which is like uh
a hundred reasons to watch avatar right
now um
which is that like do they all spend the
rest of their lives together with their
first crushes
yeah it's very harry pottery yeah i mean
you know it's definitely another one of
those things where it's like
this show is made for a younger audience
and in your head when you're younger
you're like
the boy i meet at summer camp is the boy
i'm going to spend the rest of my life
with
so you know that's kind of what they got
to do but yeah i
i ignore that part everyone literally
everyone meets their otp when they're
like
12. yeah
you're my soul mate okay i mean do they
deserve first base
yes they've all worked very hard
these are those trauma-based
relationships that that they warned us
about at the end of speed
that didn't even last into speed to
cruise control so right yeah
no he's gonna be dating um uh uh oh
shoot what's his face and speed two
darn it uh william oh no
jason james jason jason patrick with the
leaches
anyways keep going
and death cabbage for cutie
oh my cabbages
my cabbages my cabbages
don't forget it
earth wind and fire
smoke slime fire and stink
never underestimate the power of stink
never underestimate the powers thank you
guys um
or see if you watched it out of order
how would you have appreciated the
cabbage runner
you have to watch it in order to fully
grasp that guy's ark
yeah yeah the best part about the
cabbage runner is uh
that the actual button is the little
throwaway line that the mbr
that the ember island players based
their play on interviews with him
that's good and i hear there's like a
legend of korra cause i read an article
about the cabbage like an oral history
of the cabbage guy
man people like this show um and it's
like
yeah wow there's a stat a statue to him
or like his descendants in uh
in in legend of korra uh so like he
became
he became a big a big i believe them but
they were just missing that
in chat chat was just saying the same
thing yeah she someone said he makes it
big in cora
he got it better than jar jar didn't in
the books
what happened to jar jar in the books oh
oh my god it's really sad actually uh so
jar jar they like it's like a short like
paragraph where they're like
the clown entertains the kids all day
and uh
the kids don't know uh what the adults
know but the adults like view him with
disdain
and essentially what happens is that jar
jar is now a homeless busker
um for children because he has been
outcast
because of his role um in in the senate
uh going down
it's great all right
he's the soccer of the uh star wars
universe
wasn't he like the didn't he pull like
uh like a reverse spartacus like didn't
he sell out the galaxy
yeah that's why he's that is why he is a
homeless busker now he's the one who
gets fooled into proposing that they
give
supreme powers to uh chancellor
palpatine yeah he's a clumsy
yeah whoopsie whoops
i don't know why they would make him a
senator obviously he's a little out of
this
that's on the that's on the naboo well
the naboo media just fell in love with
the wacky guy who had no chance of
winning
and it became a big meme and all the
youngsters in naboo voted for the guy
and here we are
he seemed like he knew what he was doing
in that boardroom
yeah everyone was real uh concerned with
padme to shake things up
yeah what's going on to boo anyways they
have they they elect a queen
that's not how it's very meaningful
the queen is always 10 or something
yeah yeah there's something screwy's
going on there stop electing child
in the spielberg lucas verse if you're
old enough to fall in love with dr jones
you're old enough to be the queen of a
planet
if you mess with his friends his dome
lights up to let enemies know
they're about to go down
saka the rodney dangerfield while you
guys are playing in the water
i'm supposed to be hard at work picking
mud out of a giant bison's feet
mud and bugs there's some slimming pills
i want you to take when should i take
them
whenever you wake up you're the leader
but your voice still cracks think of all
the people who love you
yeah i like cool hey i wanted so badly
for this one
your future is full of struggle and
anguish
but you didn't read my palms or anything
it's written all over your face
i don't get no respect no respect from
anyone and
deus ex opera
oh we get it already a job that's much
harder
because he keeps saving the avatar
starring blue arrow fifth element
supreme bang bender bending rodriguez
yip-yip man
you wouldn't like him when he's angry
the dalai lama
squirtle sleet fighter aquafina
gatorade looper
foot devil school of rock barefoot and
impregnable
zuki yo do you want to know how i got
these scars
flame on the dragon prince
mark zuckerberg i row right
my neighbor flotaro thank you for flying
bison air marcel fry clops
luke in the last jedi remake the plot of
hamilton
your final test is a duo did you know
qatar's mom died
ever since mom died i've been doing all
the work around camp they killed my
mother
i went through the same thing when i
lost my mom i lost my mother in a fire
nation raid
saka and i lost our mother to the fire
nation the fire nation took my mother
away from me
you could bring my mother back mom
i can't believe oh swamp
and going avatar mode to save his
friends
and going avatar mode to save soccer the
people of the world so
it was uh it was hard to show but uh
aang's avatar mode gets triggered very
clearly
when uh he sees his like old
mentor and guardian dead and when oppa's
in trouble
and when qatar is in trouble and then
there's multiple moments where like
saka is like in the ground like he's
trapped like and there's a four like
trying to murder him he's like
i don't know what to do i'm sorry buddy
they're all boomerang at it
i gotta check out this cave
yeah walk it off poor guy uh anyway
sorry keep going
the people of the world are terrified by
the fire nation
they don't see our greatness they hate
us and we deserve it
yeah you tell them zuko oh we're the
fire nation aren't we
and have a cart the green leaf vendor
oh my god
not the james cameron one not james
cameron's avatar
a song of ice and fire and earth
and air i intend to remove
the moon as a factor remove the moon
how i love that admiral xiao is a big mr
show fan
another one for us uh yeah yeah our
efforts blow up the moon
we will blow up the moon my first note
on my first pass at this script my first
note from spencer was that
uh because i just had monk parentheses
just use this
logo for money and my note was you have
to write other jokes
i think monkey smoke is pretty funny
yeah it is pretty funny
like being like here's my walk-off home
run and then so and
or like mic dropping when you weren't
supposed to and someone just being like
not quite i thought i will say when i
put down bender bending rodriguez i was
like this is going to be it this is the
one
that's i thought i don't know this is a
democracy in here
if you just you're allowed to talk back
like if i don't like it like
fight for it one not really but also no
i think
like i agree the jokes that made it in
are like you know it's fine i just said
like you know sometimes you come up with
something and you're like
definitely getting in the final draft
and then whoever said this is guitar
she's got my back out because i i was
like very pleased with every
because that was a little later and i
was like oh man all these guitar jokes
are
and then whoever dropped in this is
katara she's got my pack i was like
well it's not about who did what but i
did do that
uh all right let's do some chat comments
what are people saying
oh wait should we also play the uh uh
the end card thing that we didn't
yes yes so a perfect storm
not working yet to throw in there uh
yeah so through various mishaps and and
uh
and tomfoolery uh uh uh no fault of
dante bros
uh bosco uh or donnie brasco we have
uh we have a fun end card for you let's
uh let's play and hear what zuko has to
say
hello zuko here
azula always lies the scar's not on the
wrong side
i must capture the avatar to restore my
honor
then everything changed when the fire
nation attacked
rufio rufio ruffy
oh
well that's awesome we'll have to get
him back when we do uh uh dragon prince
and work it in proper or he's in uh he's
in hook again
i mean and hook again yeah yeah he's in
korra
uh well perfect so we'll do we'll do
cora we'll do
we'll do more we'll do cora um all right
so some chat comments adam holbert
writes
we i do appreciate danielle's water
bending moves i believe that's on the
thumbnail right now
uh what kind of bender would anyone else
be you know joel on
what you bendin oh wow
earth because i never uh relax and i'm
always very
tense and uh like that so yeah
i also feel like i probably have like
the build and the body type of an earth
bender like i don't feel like i would be
in like the water bending
tribe on like some raft and like you
know
i think that's feels like a natural
place i would fit i would be one of like
the heavyset dudes hanging out in eros
tea house in bossing
got it you are definitely more of just a
white lotus guy no bending but
definitely
yeah i feel like i was like wise
but until you master your emotions you
will never masturbate
i was thinking stink bender but i feel
like airbender you get the best of both
worlds because
you can just shoot the stink i forgot
stink bending was an option
obviously that's right oh she's a water
well unless you disagree
but on the on the thumbnail you're a
water bender daniel no i think that's
fair
um i i i will say again spencer i think
that uh if you get that base going
uh you can be a stank bender
uh yeah if you get funked up deep enough
in the pocket you become a sting
all right philip demick writes uh can
anyone explain why the movie is so hated
well watch the movie watch terrible
source material then watch the movie
i mean i think in addition to just not
being very good it makes
changes and you can't for the like it
makes
it makes big changes and they're not
better like it doesn't improve anything
so just like why are like people don't
like that no one likes
that why would you randomly change
things if it's not an improvement
yeah it looks worse it is worse
everything about it's worse um so
uh d.a barakas uh uh and uh bear zerger
respectively are giving uh us props or
joe props to
uh for recommending the dragon prince um
and bear zerger is going to watch
a ghost dog which apparently is on
youtube i'm gonna watch it right now
yes so we're doing the lord's sleep oh
give it give it like 30 40
i think to see if it's for you
takes a little time to to build
yeah it's just quite a bit of time uh
quite a bit uh all right zachary dahlia
writes uh
i don't know if it's in the 100 reasons
video i think it might be but azula's
evil and craziness had more depth than
ozai's that's true that's true
oh yeah for sure i mean we don't really
even meet ozai as a character until the
final season he's like a
an outline until yeah zuma gets a lot
more time to sort of develop yeah
it was also great um uh you know
obviously it's a it's our
eight minute honest trailer uh and not
the air job that i wanted to give the
whole thing but if i could
uh you know i would i love um
that the show and we talked about it in
that 100 reasons video
but uh book two azula's just this
horrible murder
person the whole time almost kills aang
and then book three they do the fun
little teen movie episode
with uh her friends and and zuko on the
beach
and um they they give you just a little
bit
of the idea that uh she's conflicted and
she's struggling and
she actually has flaws and she might
actually be a person and then like
but then they just pull the rug out from
that like right away uh which i really
like because i think
for a show that is for younger people i
i think um
this the safer choice would have been
that she renames herself by the end too
uh and i love that they just do not go
that way they give you like a spark like
a seed and then just
throw it away which i really love
yeah i mean i think it makes the
redemption of other characters more
impactful when not every character
automatically gets redeemed
yeah there you go um
moving on yoni the k writes i don't hate
you honest trailers
well we don't hate you either you don't
need a k
uh high voltage no that's the i
that's uh that's zuko and uh
um mei's uh i love you i love you too
okay
i feel better um toonjay correcting
me uh dante bosco is an american drag
and not dragon prince excuse me that's a
different
stop what's his name jake jack jack
something
desena right yeah he's in anyways
and then finally uh sergio hernandez
will we'll we'll go out with this one
who is your most underrated character in
the franchise who do you think doesn't
get there
get doesn't get their due that's an
interesting
i i really like the uh weird professor
professor
lay lee whoever they meet on their way
to that like library
i like that whole library episode where
they lose oppa
in the library chasing them but that's
really like they have a lot of those fun
show up for an episode or two supporting
characters i also really like clancy
brown as like the big
season two villain at bossing say i'm
forgetting the character's name
where he's like the running the
brainwashing operation yeah
yeah that's a really cool like mid-show
nemesis
yeah he's great uh i'm sure he's not
underrated because i'm not on
tumblr but uh i really like jet i'm a
jet guy
yeah it was very cool that's not
election
he was willing to do you know what had
to be done
and i think that uh uh these kids they
don't realize they're in a war granted
it's been going very slowly for a
hundred years but sometimes you gotta do
what you gotta do so i was uh i was a
big jet guy
throughout the throughout this series i
like my and i again probably not super
like
underrated but i'm a huge i'm a huge my
my fan
maze great and then uh yeah i love uh
i'm trying to think of an underrated
care
i feel like everyone pretty much like
gets their
due pretty well with the show which i
like um
yeah everybody who's recurring at least
gets like an episode or two
to sort of you know focus on yeah and
they do a really good job of being like
hey you liked this person from that one
episode they're going to show up for the
invasion
right you know what i feel like the
cabbages get all the shine and the cart
that carries the cabbages get nothing
i think you just described the problems
with capitalism
all right well on that note uh and
that's all shine that's all for avatar
the last airbender please come join us
next week where we will be discussing
a film that just won't die
um and uh and we hope you like that one
too but you won't like it as much as
avatar it's not that almost definitely
not
but we'll have fun with it and i hope
next week here on australia commentaries
thanks for watching
you